[Music]
one of the biggest challenges for web
developer is to maintain asynchronous
callback based code in firebase
everything is real-time so it only makes
sense that we use the best reactive
programming library out there which is
rxjs in today's video you'll learn about
a brand new officially supported library
from firebase called rx fire we'll use
it along with stencil Jas to compose
full stack reactive web components that
can be used in any JavaScript framework
or just in some plain HTML if you're new
here like and subscribe and grab the
full source code from angular
firebase.com let's start by talking a
little bit more about what rx fire is
and when you would want to use it the
first thing I'll point out is that it's
not a replacement for angular fire - so
you want to continue using angular fire
- in an angular project but it does
provide a way for other frameworks to
have a consistent implementation of
firebase with rxjs so you can get really
good control flow on your real time
streams whether you're using view react
stencil as we'll see later in the video
or just plain JavaScript I recommend
taking a look at the RX fire samples
repo so you can see it in action in a
variety of different settings and
another really cool thing about this
library is that it doesn't take the
firebase SDK as a hard dependency which
opens the door for lazy loading the
firebase SDK is pretty large so if you
can get it out of your critical path
you'll get much quicker page loads for
your progressive web app so what I want
to show you today is how we can take
this library and use it with a web
component tool like stencil j/s to build
a reusable to-do list that you can just
drop into any other app that's already
using firebase there's a ton of
potential here to build web components
that get reused across multiple
applications for example you might build
a chat client that is similar to
intercom or maybe you just want to have
a consistent login button that you can
easily share across multiple web
applications there's just tons of
potential there but it's time to get
moving on to the code I'm going to start
by initializing stencil if you're not
familiar with stencil don't worry it's a
very approachable tool for building web
components I'm going to give it a
dedicated video in the near future but
it should feel pretty comfortable for
you if you're an angular or react
we just run npm and knit stencil and
then we select a project name and we'll
pick the starter component project which
is just for one-off web components if we
open up the project we should see a
single component in the source directory
that's where we're going to build out
our to-do list for now we can run npm
run start from the command line and that
will serve our web component in the
browser it has some basic text for now
but we'll build this out into a web
component that can handle user
authentication and also the creating
reading and deleting of data in the
firestore database if we look at how
this component is used across multiple
frameworks you can see that it's just a
script tag along with a custom element
that we can declare in the Dom at the
end of the video we'll build this
component and then we'll install it into
an existing angular project but for now
we need a couple extra things in our
stencil project including our Xfire
firebase and rxjs we could initialize
firebase directly in our web component
but I want my component to be agnostic
to the firebase project meaning you
could just drop this component into any
firebase project it should pick up the
config and work seamlessly from there so
to do that I'm just going to follow the
web setup instructions that you can find
in the official Docs and we'll only be
using fire store and user authentication
then in the script tag we'll just go
ahead and call firebase initialize app
with our credentials and then we'll also
go ahead and configure fire store here
as well now we'll go ahead and jump into
our stencil web component and you'll
notice that it looks pretty similar to
an angular or react component it has
these prop decorators which allow you to
pass in information from the HTML
directly similar to the input decorator
and angular but the decorator that we
want to use is state and this property
will rerender the component anytime it's
value changes and that's actually a
really nice mechanism for working with
our Xfire because every time our
observable emits some new data or the
data changes it will rerender the
component in the UI this component will
have two different stateful objects
which represent our real-time streams
one is the to-do list which will be in
fire store and the other one is the user
which is the user authentication account
then we're not going to actually import
firebase in this component because we
don't want it as a hard dependency so
I'll go ahead and run
that types for firebase just for
intellisense up at the top and the first
thing we'll do with our Xfire is observe
the user's authentication state state is
just a function that returns an
observable and that observable will
either you met null if the users not
logged in or it will emit their user off
account if they are logged in then we
have a bunch of different functions for
working with firestore if we want to
just get the raw data from the
collection we can use collection data or
if we want more fine-grained control
there's a number of different methods
that allow you to observe specific
changes to the documents in your
database the first thing we want to do
in our component is observe the users
off state stencyl has a life cycle hook
called component will load which is
roughly the equivalent to ng on a knit
and angular so we've initialized
firebase outside of this component so
I'm going to declare a global variable
for firebase and then type it to the
firebase app this step is just so we get
Intelli sense with our typescript in vs
code then going down to the component
we'll lifecycle hook we're going to
subscribe to the off state of the
firebase user and then the value that
this observable emits will be the state
of the user property on our component so
now whenever this observable emits
something it will rerender the component
based on the logic that we have down
here in our render function for right
now we'll just inspect that we actually
have a logged in user by json stringify
in the user object then our component
will automatically reload when we save
it and you'll notice that it says hello
world null that's because we're not
logged in to fix that we'll go ahead and
add a login and logout button to our
component I'm going to be using Google
auth so make sure you have that enabled
on the firebase dashboard first we'll
set a variable called provider that is a
new instance of the Google auth provider
then we can say firebase auth sign in
with pop up and that's all we need to do
to get logged in to a Google account and
while we're at it let's go ahead and
create a logout method that's just a
single line of code saying firebase auth
sign out the next thing we want to do is
rewrite this render function so that if
the users logged in we show them the
to-do list and a sign out button
otherwise we show them the
with Google button in TSX we can handle
events such as clicks by saying on click
followed by brackets and the method that
we want to call in this case login if
the users logged in we'll go ahead and
show them their display name and we'll
also give them a button to log out if we
go back to the app now and click the
login button you'll see that firebase
does its thing with a pop-up window for
Google authentication then when that
off-state changes it will rerender that
component to show the users display name
and the logout button so basically we
just created a Google login web
component that can be used anywhere with
any framework but I want to take things
a step further and build a to-do list
for this user in firestore that is only
associated with this user and this is
actually really easy to do thanks to our
Xfire so I'm bringing in the switch map
operator from rxjs
then I'm making a reference to a
firestore collection that contains all
the - dues for all of our users we'll
get to the database in just a minute
but what I'm going to do is save a user
property on every to-do item then I'll
query it based on the user's
authentication UID so we'll go ahead and
create an observable that's based on the
off state and then we'll switch map to a
different observable of the collection
and fire store when we run switch map
it's kind of like being inside of
subscribe so we'll have access to the
user object at that point we can make a
query on the reference that we set
earlier so we'll create a query that
says get all - duze where the user is
equal to this users user ID then we can
get all of that collections data
unwrapped by just calling collection
data with this query object and then the
final step is just to subscribe to this
observable and then we'll set its value
equal to that to do state on the
component and the last thing we'll do is
go down to our render function and then
just display it as JSON for now to make
sure that it's working right now it
displays an empty array because we don't
have any data in our database so let's
go ahead and change that the beauty of
this setup is that our component will
rerender anytime our real-time data
changes we can demonstrate this by
creating our - duze collection and then
we'll create a document in that
collection where the user property is
equal to this users ID I'm just copying
the user ID from the UI over to our
document
and as soon as we click save on this
document it will be updated in the UI in
our stencil component on the left and
any changes that happen to this document
no matter where it comes from will
trigger this component to be rendered
then just to prove that our relational
data is set up properly I'm gonna create
another document but this time give it a
user that's different than the currently
authenticated user you'll notice that
nothing renders in the UI because our
query is based on only the to Do's for
the currently logged in user another
thing our expire does is it tries to
make life easier for you for example a
common need is to have the document ID
map to every document in the collection
normally that takes a bunch of
JavaScript mapping but in our Xfire we
can just pass in the field that we want
the ID map to and it will return that
data for us without any additional work
now we can go back into our render
function and this time we'll loop over
the array of documents and map each one
of them to a list item and you'll notice
that I have a property on this list
called task ID which is what I defined
in that collection data method above and
the reason you give it your own custom
property name instead of just ID is in
case you already have an existing ID
that you don't want to overwrite I've
also added a create and delete method
here which you can find in the full
source code and our finished product
looks something like this it's not very
pretty from a design standpoint but it's
a real-time full stack web component
which is pretty impressive on its own
but I promised you that we'd be able to
run this web component anywhere and the
first step in that process is to run a
production build and stencil the stencil
project itself sets you up to build an
NPM package that you can either install
locally or publish on NPM after our
build is finished we'll go ahead and
copy the path to this project folder and
then we can use that path to install an
NPM package in a completely different
project I happen to have an existing
angular project that has angular fire to
and firebase already installed in it but
I'd like to reuse my stencil to do lists
because I've already written this code
and I don't want to have to rewrite
everything in angular so let's see if we
can make our stencil component work in
this angular project the first thing
you'll do is run NPM install in the
angular project and have it point to the
path of your stencil project if you
didn't change any of the defaults that
should resolve to 8
my component version 0.01 in angular we
have to enable that custom element
schema so you can import that from
angular core then add that to the
schemas array in the app module the
final step is to bootstrap the custom
elements in this project by calling
define custom elements which is provided
by stencil we can handle that in the
main TS file so we'll import defined
custom elements from my component and
then we'll also register firebase on the
window object so it's available there as
well and lastly we'll call defined
custom elements and pass at the window
at this point we can use our web
component anywhere in this angular
project as if it was just a regular Dom
element I'm just going to go ahead and
declare my component in the app
component HTML and we'll see what
happens as you can see here we have our
login with Google button and once we log
in we get our to-do list from the
database so hopefully this video gave
you a decent introduction into how easy
it is to work with real time streams
when you combine rxjs with firebase I'm
going to go ahead and wrap things up
there but I have a lot more content plan
for our Xfire and stencil in the future
let me know what you want to see next in
the comments and consider upgrading to a
pro membership to get access to all
kinds of exclusive content thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon